Remember that the equation we had before.
If the amount of money that Grant would
earn if all of his original orders had
gone through, was equal to 87w plus 72n.
But this was before any orders had been
canceled. And in the last quiz, we just
found out how much money Grant would have
earned from the orders that are now
canceled. And that was just equal to 3w
plus 12n dollars. A couple of quizzes ago,
we also found an equation for Grant's
total future earnings, taking his canceled
orders into account. Of course, it was a
pretty general equation, that didn't have
any variables numbers in it yet. They said
that his total future earnings will be
equal to the money from all the original
orders, minus the money he would have made
from the orders that are now canceled. So
let's combine all this information, using
substitutions, into a single equation, for
Grant's total future earnings. Earnings.
So which of these expressions down here
would correctly replace the question mark
to come up with an equation for Grant's
total future earnings, taking the cost of
each wiper and nozzle into account.